sahara occidental encore de france est
aux mains du front polisario pour la
justice allemande bader et ses deux
compagnons se sont bien suicidé raymond
barre pas question d'une cinquième
semaine de congés
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui à la facilité
40 milliards pour les rapatrier les
explications de jacques demy net
le monsieur bonsoir encore deux français
disparus en mauritanie il est beaucoup
trop tôt pour dire s'ils ont été ou non
enlevé par le polisario le mouvement
d'indépendance du peuple sahraoui
affirme ce soir tout ignorer du sort de
ces deux techniciens détaché par la sncf
pour travailler pour le compte d'une
société minière mauritanienne raymond
bâcle et claude miguet ont disparu en
compagnie de 15 mauritanien et il est
tentant bien sûr de rapprocher
l'événement de l'enlèvement de six
français le 1er mai dernier
six français dont on n'a toujours aucune
nouvelle près de sept kilomètres c'est
le train le plus long du monde celui qui
emmène le minerai de fer 2 waratahs la
côte atlantique 600 km de désert
c'est ce train qui a été attaqué il ya
quelques jours par le polisario et c'est
en allant vérifier les voit que les deux
techniciens français et leur équipe
mauritanienne ont disparu on a perdu
leur contact radio en fin d'après midi
alors qu'il se trouvait à une
soixantaine de km 2 where art et sans
escorte militaire semble-t-il ce qui
porte à huit le nombre des français
disparus la bas monsieur eudeline était
responsable de la sécurité à zuera tc
nouvelle disparition ne le surprennent
pas la guerre a commencé le 1er était
5,75
nous avions subi déjà plusieurs attaques
j'avais réclamé l'évacuation des
familles en particulier et j'avais fait
de nombreux apports le résultat était
que j'étais licencié expulsés de man et
année le 96 ça tout de même les français
qui sont la bad de même que ceux qui
lisent y emploie d'ailleurs ça vient
depuis le temps qu'il y à des risques
certains travaillaient sourate alors
comment se fait-il que des gens s'y
fasse encore enlevé et bien dès le début
la position de la prise par la direction
de comédiens étaient absolument
aberrante
c'est à dire que l'on cherche à cacher
aux expatriés qui travaillent à zouara
thierry suc ils courent n'est ce pas
comment eh ben on se refait le silence
en particulier sur les attentats qui ont
eu lieu le long de la voie ferrée et qui
sont très fréquents de la doller
d'attentats par mois environ dans depuis
soixante-quinze jusqu'au
jusqu à 1077 et que fait l'armée
mauritanienne l'armée maté n'y était un
homme extrêmement jeune qui vient d'être
formé qui est composée en majorité on
peut dire de noirs qui sont pas deux qui
ne sont pas déjà habitué à laver à la
vitre et rue du désert et qui se trouve
par contre opposée à des sahraouis qui
vivent évidemment comme des poissons
dans l'eau si l'on peut dire donc ça
n'est ce pas qui ont l'habitude de
rouler de nuit comme de jour sans
problème quelle que soit la chaleur
puisque tu as beaucoup plus actif l'été
que le quolibet il est évident que pour
eux en plus ils ont la lisons le rôle de
l'assaillant qui est drôle le plus
facile la défense est toujours très
délicate et qui ont également des
probablement d intelligence dans la
place par ailleurs oui il est certain
que dans la population la population
mauritanienne de swat est composée
surtout de nomades et on peut dire que
ce roman à 50% des habitants de soi sont
favorables au polisario
il y avait 300 français à se verra temps
mais ils ne sont plus que 75 qui
cherchent à partir c'est l'objectif visé
par le polisario qui par le biais des
prises d'otage cherchent à casser les
rapports de coopération franco
mauritanien et qui par ailleurs souhaite
une prise de contact direct avec la
france
effectivement ne sont pas contre c'est
ce que nous déclarait le premier
ministre sahraoui en septembre et il a
ajouté nous attendons nous sommes prêts
mais une prise de contact directe ce
serait une reconnaissance implicite de
la république sahraouie et c'est là
l'autre objectif du polisario
oui rares sont les pays arabe à avoir
reconnu le polisario l'algérie
pratiquement l'un des seul sait pourquoi
on s'attendait ce que lionel stoléru
socata d'état en visite à alger évoque
le problème mais le ministre à son
retour n'a pas voulu tout à leur
dévoiler la teneur de ces conversations
bien entendu quand il ya un français
quel qu'il soit qui ont quelque part
dans le monde est en danger
il est tout à fait évident que
l'ensemble du gouvernement français est
mobilisé pour faire l'impossible pour
qu'ils reviennent sains et saufs sur le
sol j'ai donc évoquer ce problème mais
comme vous en doutez ce n'est pas un
sujet idéal pour une discussion publique
je préfère que les négociations qui sont
en cours continuent à être menées
discrètement et efficacement
est-ce que vous avez quand même eu des
nouvelles de leur santé je ne peux pas
faire de commentaire sur ce sujet c'est
une confirmation officielle andreas
baader yann carl raspe e et gudrun
ensslin se sont bien suicidé voilà ce
qu'affirme le rapport du ministère de la
justice de l'état de bade wurtemberg et
cela au moment même où on apprenait que
l'on avait fait de nouvelles découvertes
dans les cellules des détenus
décidément transformé en caserne d'ali
baba les transistors et des écouteurs ce
qui pourrait expliquer la façon dont les
terroristes ont appris l'échec du
détournement de la lufthansa
tout cela donc dans une atmosphère de
malaise à stuttgart depuis que le maire
de la ville a décidé d'autoriser
l'inhumation de baladeurs et de deux de
ses complices
demain dans le cimetière local
dans ce cimetière de donnera lé 2 dans
la banlieue de stuttgart
les ouvriers communaux sont déjà à
l'ouvragé c'est ici que seront intérêts
demain andreas baader gudrun ensslin et
yann carl raspe les membres du noyau dur
du terrorisme allemands seront inhumés à
proximité d'un autre cimetière qui était
jusqu alors réservé par tradition à des
résistants au nazisme et aux dignitaires
de l'allemagne de l'après-guerre
ce simple fait dépassent la mesure pour
la majorité des allemands et
singulièrement les habitants de
stuttgart depuis trois jours c'est
l'indignation dans la capitale du bade
wurtemberg pour l'homme de la rue bader
et ses amis n'ont pas mérité d'être
enseveli à stuttgart
ils n'en sont pas dignes et nous dit
c'est pas ça le maire manfred romel
c'est le fils du général rommel c'est
cependant déterminé pour l'apaisement
pour lui l'amour et fasse pas maintenant
il ya beaucoup de protest mais c'est
tout plaire après tout des événements le
mode ces messieurs flyers il ya une
grande agressions contre les terroristes
mais si l'on est mort c'est fini ce qui
est loin d'être terminée celle enquête
sur les circonstances des suicides deux
tours diack chaman un rapport a été
rendu public aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement régional de bade-wurtemberg
il confirme la thèse des suicides
d'andreas baader de goudron ans line et
de race peu mais il ne donne pas toute
la lumière sur les négligences graves
ayant permis aux détenus les mieux
gardés d'allemagne de pouvoir se
procurer arme et radio en attendant des
mesures de sécurité exceptionnelles sont
maintenus autour de la prison de joux
times où les drapeaux reste en berne en
signe de deuil pour hans martin flyers à
paris deux mouvements l'un d'extrême
gauche claude d'extrême droite partit
des forces nouvelles avaient appelé à
manifester tout à l'heure à 18 heures
devant l'ambassade d'allemagne
les deux manifestations avaient été
interdites mais quelques manifestants se
trouvaient quand même devant l'ambassade
de rfa et tout à l'heure au téléphone
philippe chat mais m'a dit
ces manifestations étaient pratiquement
terminées je t'ai pas si vous êtes comme
moi mais je suis toujours étonné pour ne
pas dire être paré quand j'apprends par
exemple que 200 tonnes de choux fleurs
ont été jetés ce matin à la décharge
publique de châteaurenard dans les
bouches du rhône
il n'avait pas trouvé d'acheteur et cela
se passe un petit peu partout surtout en
bretagne alors que toutes les ménagères
sur les marchés dans les grandes villes
savent qu un chou-fleur ça se paie cher
trop cher même je crois que voilà bien
résumée à l'absurde le problème du
contrôle des prix alimentaires l'indicé
des prix de septembre ne sera connue
qu'après demain
mais d'ores et déjà on sait qu'il ne
sera pas bon on parle d'une hausse de 0
8% et toujours donc un accusé numéro un
les prises alimentaires ce qui importe
le plus pour une ménagère c'est le prix
marquer sur l'étiquette mais il est
peut-être intéressant de regarder plus
loin ses carottes par exemple acheté
entre un front dit c'est un franc 40 le
kilo sont payés 12 centimes aux
producteurs ces poireaux acheté 2 prend
20 le kilo au marché le producteur les a
vendues entre 60 et 70 centimes le kilo
cette laitue à 1 franc pièce et le
rapport de 25 à 35 centimes aux
producteurs quant aux choux fleurs
malgré la surproduction on le trouve sur
le marché autour de trois femmes que
j'ai trouvé un chou-fleur à quel prix
moyen du madame stoller 3 france 5 arte
ici et aujourd'hui il est à 295 mec ya
c'est arrivé c'est tout le monde vaque
sa vie sur terre le gars qui a arraché
souffleur le gars qui les fait pousser
le bac et des transports le bas qui les
vend il a vendu ce qui est derrière
je voulais mais j'ai quand même pris
qu'ils ont tué lui aussi dont trois
franches ou fleurs non non non aux prix
des loyers au prix de l'essence aux prix
des des chaussures à 50 mille francs
dans les magasins et un truc comme ça
non
non et même aberrant oui trois francs le
kg alors que 65 centimes seulement à la
production on peut s'étonner après une
brève tournée d'explication à alger à
tunis je vous le disais lionel stoléru
secrétaire d'état chargé des
travailleurs immigrés a décidé de mettre
les choses au point
le conseil d'état n'avait pas émis un
avis favorable sur son décret à propos
de l'immigration familiale reste les
rues a donc décidé que cette immigration
des familles des travailleurs immigrés
serait maintenu mais sous certaines
conditions condition numéro un les
femmes et les enfants d'un étranger qui
travaillent en france s'engageront à ne
pas demander d'emplois dans l'hexagone
mais ils pourront rejoindre le chef de
famille une réponse de raymond barre à
la proposition d'andré bergeron qui
souhaitaient une cinquième semaine de
congés payés
une réponse qui n'a rien d'encourageant
pour le leader de force ouvrière
tout comme michel debré qui posait la
question tout à l'heure à l'assemblée
par le ministre s'est déclaré hostile à
l'idée dans l'état que les choses
écoutons le parler à l'heure actuelle et
à très brève échéance d'une cinquième
semaine de congés payés c'est ne pas
tenir compte des exigences de l'effort
individuel et collectif qui s'impose à
ce pays
nous continuons un peu trop souvent à
vivre peut-être à cause des
circonstances dans lesquelles nous nous
trouvons comme si la france n'avait pas
à payer la facture pétrolière comme si
la france n'avait pas à investir comme
si la france n'avait pas à mener une
politique spécifique en matière d'emploi
vous savez que le gouvernement a pris un
certain nombre de décisions qui ne vont
pas dans le sens de la facilité
et puis je crois qu'il faut aussi dire
quelque chose est ce que dans les années
à venir notre économie sera en mesure de
supporter des superstructures sociales
qui sont souvent beaucoup plus
généreuses que celles que l'on trouve
chez nos principaux rivaux
raymond barre qui va s'envoler demain
pour budapest un voyage de trois jours
ans
le conseil constitutionnel a retrouvé
tous ses membres louis joxe a été nommé
au fauteuil qu'occupait en rirait
disparu il ya quinze jours
félix gouin est mort il avait 93 ans ce
fut le successeur du général de gaulle à
la tête du gouvernement provisoire et à
ce titre pendant six mois il fut tout à
la fois chef de l'état et président du
conseil des congés élections pour les
salariés qui voudraient se lancer dans
la bataille électorale
ainsi en a décidé le conseil des
ministres sur une proposition de
christian bilhac un congé de 10 jours
avec l'obligation pour le chef
d'entreprise de reprendre le salarié au
terme du premier mandat
deuxième décision du conseil des
ministres elle a plus de poids et de
porter l'indemnisation des rapatriés
elle sera portée à 40 milliards
une loi d'il ya sept ans avait prévu 10
milliards le nouveau projet loi
d'aujourd'hui prévoit 30 milliards
d'indemnités supplémentaires indemnité
payable en bon sur cinq ans premières
réactions chez les rapatrier celle du
mouvement recours les rapatriés sont
conscients que la nouvelle loi
correspond à un effort important est
qu'elle est de nature à rendre justice à
notre communauté dans la mesure où les
amendements qui sont souhaitables
pouvons être apportée par l'assemblée
nationale au cours d'un débat que nous
voulons très ouvert il est évident que
compte tenu de l'art d'oise à régler
n'est pas possible de pratiquer une
indemnisation
sur une durée très courte et il était
nécessaire qu'elle soit étalé dans le
temps et nous comprenons bien
néanmoins il est absolument
indispensable que les titres qui seront
délivrés aux rapatriés les titres ou les
certificats d indemnisation soit indexée
de façon à ce qu'il ne perde pas de leur
valeur la formule choisie pour
indemniser les personnes âgées vous
partagez cette saison un peu lente
aussi je compte les personnes âgées ne
veut recevoir leurs tics prioritaire dès
le début de l'année 78 et qu'ils
puissent les négocier très rapidement
voilà avec nous pour répondre à ces
questions jacques dominati ce fait à
d'état auprès du premier chargé
notamment des rapatriés
alors précisément sur ces deux questions
d'abord l'indexation des bons indexation
les bons sont indexés à partir du 1er
janvier 78
ils sont indexés à cette date et ensuite
ils portent intérêt à 6 5%
je note surtout la satisfaction du monde
rapatriés et satisfaire une satisfaction
morale d'abord puisque la loi
d'indemnisation reconnaît leur droit
minutieux de très important le demande
est soutenue et je note aussi que les
rapatriés sont bien content c'est un
effort considérable qui est fait
effectivement 40 divia mais c'est un
effort considérable mais supportable
parce que le gouvernement a étudié le
les moyens financiers pour que ce soit
étalée dans le temps
or justement pour répondre à la deuxième
question du roseau ou est-ce qu'on ne
pouvait pas aller plus vite pour les
personnes âgées
nous essaierons d'aller plus vite les
personnes âgées seront en quelque sorte
indemnisés en cinq ans 5 annuités à
partir du 1er janvier d'ailleurs 78 et
si effectivement nous pouvons donner les
bons dans le premier trimestre nous le
ferons mais la loi est une loi qui est
juste et c'est une loi qui est généreuse
mais ce n'est pas une loi électorale
four dans le premier trimestre
distribuer les bons elle est un peu
tardif quand même 15 ans après
on s'y prend maintenant à quatre mois
d'élections vatan vous dire vous avez
raison de poser la question mais il faut
bien comprendre que c'est le président
de la république qui a accepté le
principe de l'indemnisation et qui a
proposé l'indemnisation jusqu'à présent
les rapatrier avait eu une aide à la
réinstallation
il y avait eu la loi de juillet 70 avait
été importante
c'était une contribution de solidarité
mais il n'était pas question de
reconnaître l'indemnisation
c'est à ces fictions net-a-porter
rapatrier alors 15 ans après c'est pour
jean paul bourre réconcilier vraiment la
communauté nationale
quel est l'état d'esprit des rapatriés
autant que vous le sentiez depuis que
vous êtes à ce poste au début il était
plutôt sceptique lorsque l'on évoqué
l'indemnisation disons le franchement il
n'y croyait pas
aujourd'hui je constate que les
critiques portent sur le détail mais sur
l'essentiel
je n'ai pas l'impression qu'il a les
critiques importantes et vous pouvez
nous promettre que vous ne serez pas un
seul état d'état électoral que le poste
ne sera pas supprimée après marson 18
mois je crois que la démonstration est
faite si j'étais inspecteur d'état
électoral de nous serions précipiter
pour imprimer des bons c'est tout ce que
nous avons l'intention de faire un
projet de loi réaliste sérieux chiffré
avec par annuités des annuités
importante avec une charge de 2
milliards 4 et qui va courir pendant
quinze ans je crois que ce n'est pas un
projet celui là je remercie dans notre
dernier journal ya soir nous vous
montrions la livraison d'un premier
airbus à la compagnie d'aviation
thaïlandaise et chaque jour 11 10 un
airbus par ci un concorde par là je
rentre de temps en temps il faudrait
s'arrêter un petit peu pour faire le
point est ce que le succès de l'airbus
n'est pas l'arbre qui cache la forêt ou
en et l'industrie aéronautique française
georges leclercq a décidé de réunir
toutes les informations qu'il a sur la
question pour essayer de dresser un
rapide bilan
le mirage
c'est la vache à lait de l'industrie
aéronautique française grâce aux 1500
appareils vendus de par le monde mirage
3 mirage 5 mirage f1 le chiffre des
exportations est bon il aurait même
doublé cette année selon monsieur ravaux
le président du groupement des
industriels aérospatiaux français en
gros de 10 milliards en 76 on passerait
à 20 milliards cette année
mais ce bon résultat les exportations ne
masque que partiellement la situation
difficile de l'ensemble de l'industrie
aéronautique française chômage
licenciements crise mévente fonds perdus
sont des mots qui reviennent plus
souvent que embauche succès
développement pourtant il faut relever
les points positifs suivant d'abord la
formidable percée des avions d'affaires
français voici le mystère 50 ou encore
falcon 50 il vient de battre deux
records mondiaux en traversant sans
escale l'atlantique nord de new york à
paris cet avion n'existe encore qu'un
seul exemplaire le second volet d'ici la
fin de l'année
il s'en est déjà vendu 40 livrables en
79 avec ses homologues mystères 10
mystères 20 ce falcon 50 permettra à
dassault de devenir dans deux ans
peut-être le premier constructeur au
monde d'avions d'affaires en tout cas
l'un des promis mais derrière tout cela
se profile des aspects négatifs
voici le transall avion de transport
militaire datant de 63 célèbre notamment
depuis l'opération du zaïre
il est construit à la fois en france par
l'aérospatiale et en allemagne depuis le
1er octobre la chaîne de production est
relancé pour 75 avions
cela donne du travail à de nombreux
employés d'aérospatiale mais jusqu'ici
seul le tiers 25 appareils a été vendue
et à l'armée française alors que va-t-on
faire du reste
et qui va payer plus fort encore voici
un petit avion de transport le nord 262
très économique
il n'est plus construit aujourd'hui
alors qu'il intéresse des compagnies
américaines la marine française et bien
d'autres clients
si on relançait deux mains la chaîne de
production pour construire deux avions
par mois
cela donnerait du travail à trois mille
personnes
au moins un cas à l'aérospatiale
pourtant personne aujourd'hui ne prend
la décision
alors pourquoi relancer le transall qui
se vend peu et par le nord 262 qui
pourrait se vendre comme des petits
pains vous le voyez la situation n'est
pas rose pour tout le monde et le succès
de l'airbus qui continue à se vendre
petit à petit et qui rapportent le tiers
du prix de vente à la france à chaque
fois ne suffit pas pour assurer les
beaux jours de ce secteur vital de
l'économie
surtout qu'aucun successeur de l'airbus
n'a encore été décidé alors que les
concurrents rafle déjà les marchés même
en europe la politique
après françois mitterrand avant-hier
rennes mon maire a rencontré ce matin
robert fabre et verra prochainement
georges marchais et de délégation cfdt
et radicaux de gauche ont fait état ce
matin je cite de très large convergence
de vues les fonctionnaires dans la rue à
l'appel de six fédérations syndicales
des manifestations ont eu lieu dans la
plupart des grandes villes de france
et puis comme tous les mercredis depuis
maintenant quatorze semaines
une nouvelle réunion des représentants
de la majorité ce matin au siège du rpr
c'est devenu une habitude comme le
conseil des ministres alors où en sont
inalco oui et si dans la majorité dans
l'opposition ne se rencontre plus au
moins pour l'instant dans la majorité on
se rencontre beaucoup c'est mieux mais
ça révèle peut-être qu'il ya aussi
quelques difficultés alors en principe
cet après midi les quatre formations de
la majorité se sont mises d'accord sur
la totalité des circonscriptions jeudi
en principe seulement car ils doivent se
revoir vendredi prochain pour signer
leur accord mais en même temps pour
analyser quand même un certain nombre de
circonscriptions qui sont réservées et
il semble que ces circonscriptions soit
quand même relativement nombreux et
c'est à ce moment là seulement que l'on
connaîtra la liste
c'est à ce moment qu'on connaîtra la
liste bien alors je crois que il ya
d'autres difficultés qui apparaissent
indépendamment de ses compositions pour
les listes électorales dans certains
discours notamment du côté de chirac on
perçoit quelques nuances
oui monsieur chirac continue
actuellement son tour de france il était
hier soir avignon ce soir à digne et
hier soir l'union l'a prononcé un mot
qui a frappé surtout venant de lui c'est
le mot désarroi il y a dit il des
arwa dans l'opinion mais il a ajouté
aussi il y as désarroi dans nos rangs
alors monsieur chirac combat ce désarroi
et les thèmes qu'il aborde chaque soir
ne sont pas des thèmes chaque soir
renouvelée mais cette espèce de
répétition leur donne de chaque jour un
peu plus d'acuité
monsieur chirac un peu agacé semble-t-il
par les sondages et par les commentaires
qui en sont faits agacé peut-être aussi
par un certain triomphalisme de
quelques-uns de ses partenaires et c'est
précisément de se démarquer de ses
partenaires alors il le fait en les
qualifiant pas toujours gentiment la
droite classique orthodoxe et libérale
itil ou la droite des notables mais il
développe aussi ses propres idées celle
par exemple d'une croissance vigoureuse
qui se pose évidemment sans que cela
soit est ouvertement à la croissance
douce choisi par le président de la
république
et puis il reprend aussi les grands mots
magiques du gaullisme la planification
la participation et s'étant déplacés
ainsi si l'on peut dire vers sa gauche
il se garde quand même sur sa droite en
reprenant un réaffirmant très fort le
thème de l'ordre réactualisé il faut
bien le dire par le terrorisme
international alors il s'en va répétant
la démocratie doit être un régime
d'autorité ainsi sans s'attaquer
ouvertement à sauver qu'il a passé un
pacte majoritaire
monsieur chirac de ville en ville
cultive sa différence et montrent que si
l'entente est solide il y à aussi au
sein de cette entente une solide
concurrence
la stat elle que nous pourrons aborder
avec monsieur chirac lorsqu'il sera
notre invité entre deux meetings encore
un discours du chef de l'état en
cassette celui de lyon distribué
précisément à 10000 personnes âgées
à l'initiative de l'association de la
démocratie c'est un moyen moderne et
laïque et c'est une heure à l'elysée une
simple visite de courtoisie au président
de la république car l'ancien secret
d'état les thèmes porteurs semble-t-il
d'aucun message de jimmy carte n'est pas
si facile d'oublier qu'on a été ministre
des affaires étrangères de l'inde et
pays
puissant du monde pendant très longtemps
ce matin une rixe entre la bonne on dit
qu'il va se reconvertir dans notre
métier le journalisme en travaillant
pour une chaîne de télévision américaine
voyez métier encore du prestige henrique
center aura peut-être d'ailleurs été
étonné d'apprendre que les états unis
s'apprêteraient à dire oui à un embargo
sur les ventes d'armes à destination de
l'afrique du sud c'est une résolution du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu et puisque
nous sommes à new york reste 11 i avec
une occupation peu banale celle de la
statue de la liberté
la spa steyer 28 porte requins avaient
envahi les lieux avant de se rendre à
l'aube pour forces de police sans
incident
et puis pour en terminer avec l'étranger
sachez qu'un second mariage entre une
étrangère et un chinois qui avait
autorisé à pékin cette fois ci ce n'est
plus une française c'est une
australienne monte cristo 77
ce n'est pas le titre d'une nouvelle
adaptation du roman d'alexandre dumas
mais une histoire vraie celle d'un
mathématicien pauvre devenu milliardaire
et qui réclament aujourd'hui justice sur
une histoire rocambolesque qui l'a
raconté à georges bégoux vous allez le
voir ça s'écoute presque comme un roman
c'est pour ne plus connaître ces heures
tragiques que le jeune mathématicien
aaron menu ce s'est exilé de sa hongrie
natale
accueilli à paris à la cité
universitaire internationale
ils allaient connaître dans cette oasis
de paix quelques années plus tard une
étrange aventure personnes à la cité
universitaire j'avais beaucoup d'amis
notamment parmi des mathématiciens dont
un s'appelait barma safari et nissan
hier il était jaloux de moi sur le plan
professionnel et un jour il a décidé de
me supprimer safari était assez là où
vous êtes
et moi j'étais assis ici il m'a demandé
de fermer la fenêtre
oui c'est ce que vous avez fait montre
et nos chats je me suis levé comme cela
avec l'intention de la fermer et c'est à
ce moment là qu'il a bondi sur moi et il
m'a pu pousser violemment dans le dos et
vous aident à l'échec
vous êtes accroché comme ça ce coup ci
m'a retenu j'ai été blessé ici et là ya
un constat médical constat médical
premier procès qui se terminera par un
non lieu
d'autres procès qui suivront c'est à
cause du même individu affirme aaron
l'onu ce qui sera renvoyée de l'école
des mines qu'il deviendra chômeurs mais
ne cessera jamais d'espérer et la
fortune et la réouverture des dossiers
absolument vital d'obtenir justice
ce que moi qui suis victime c'est moi
qui a été exclu en quelques soif de la
société à l'autre histoire c'est un peu
monté cristo rouis ccsa vous êtes devenu
riche pour pouvoir faire payer
maintenant le prix aux autres ce qui
vous ennuie
je ne cherche pas la vengeance mais je
cherche la justice
menus se reconvertit dans la bourse a
commencé à s'enrichir en prévoyant
mathématiquement la crise du sucre
ici à la cave c'est mon cerveau
électronique qui alimente l'écran de
télévision dans mon appartement je suis
le seul particulier en france havas cet
appareil à mon domicile
avec cet appareil je suis relié avec
toutes les bourses du monde y est ce
pour ça vient très compliqué tout ça
quelle méthode avez vous apporté à la
bourse
j'ai trouvé une méthode en appliquant
des mathématiques la bourse des matières
premières
au début j'étais conseil et maintenant
je suis arrivé à gérer mon propre argent
et en deux ou trois ans peut-être quatre
où j'ai gagné beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
en tout cas plus d'un million de francs
actuels et le sentiment aujourd'hui
d'être milliardaire vous amène à voir la
vie plus heureuse c'est facile et oui et
en tout cas je me sens en sécurité
mais l'argent c'est pas toujours la
sécurité par exemple vous risquez
maintenant d'être envahi par des gens
qui vous demandent de l'argent peut-être
risqué ou un enlèvement qui sait
j'espère que non en tout cas je préfère
recevoir des lettres de demande plutôt
que s'évader sommation d'huissier des
payer
l'ancien petit professeur de
mathématiques est aujourd'hui en passe
de retrouver une dignité qu'il a de
bonnes raisons d'estimé piétiner depuis
13 ans j'ai un très grand espoir
il ya des décisions prises déjà
c'est-à-dire de rouvrir certains
dossiers par un peu dossier de la
tentative d'assassinât et du vol ils se
passeraient quand il ya une audience sur
le fond de la sphère le 21 novembre
prochain
là
c'est une histoire vraie avant de vous
quitter je voudrais vous rappeler notre
magazine dans moins de cinq minutes
maintenant dans le cadre de question de
temps louis blériot présentera un
reportage assez passionnant sur le nord
pas de calais réalisé par eric louis guy
claisse et philippe gildas à reportage
qui sera suivie d'une discussion avec
françois et sig le délégué à
l'aménagement du territoire
puis cette séquence or en rugby les all
blacks pour leur premier match en terre
française ont écrasé une sélection en 16
à brive
j'ose à peine vous le dire 45 à 3 la
météo maintenant et bien quelques pluies
demain sur toute la bande de l'extrême
est du pays
attention aussi au brouillard notamment
sur le nord le bassin parisien et la
franche-comté un brouillard qui pourra
rester pendant toute la journée
ailleurs il devrait faire beau voilà
vous avez deux rendez vous donc avec
l'information à 20h30 le magazine et
puis à 22h54 comme on dit la sncf le
dernier journal avec pour chef de gare
gérard holtz bonne soirée à tous à
demain